[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui le samsung galaxy s 800 en
france et j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
l'essayer le prend dans les mains et
pouvoir réellement pour tout te dire
cette fois ci ce que j'en pense
le suit et légers fins et vachement
agréable à tenir en main quand tu as
dans la main tu te rends vraiment compte
que c'est un objet qui est petit qui est
hyper maniable et qui est vraiment super
agréable à tenir notamment alors l'écran
est aussi père confort au regard des 5,8
pouces super amoled
c'est un écran effectivement tu as dû
borderless en écran légèrement incurvé
ce qui fait que la partie écran occupe
quasiment la totalité du smartphone ça
tu sais on en a déjà parlé mais c'est
vrai que il ya une différence entre en
parler et voir les vidéos directement
chez samsung et tenir le smartphone dans
tes mains
une femme qu'elle entame un tu peux te
rends compte vraiment que c'est un
produit qui est vraiment super sympa
très agréable à regarder et ont pour
l'instant tout ce que j'ai vu que
j'étais ici en termes de smartphones en
termes de qualité et je dirais de
plaisir de lecture
c'est top alors le seul bémol on sent
qu'elle ferait attention c'est comme on
est sur un écran en verre
attention à la casse il est normalement
équipée d'un système qui le consolide et
qui évite qu'on le casque en échappant
et en faisant tomber mais ça on sait
très bien qu'il n'ya rien infaillible ça
dépend qui tombe sur une petite pierre
sur quelque chose qui sur une perfection
rien est un feuillet les effectivement
le téléphone parce que c'est donc c'est
un petit peu géré le point sensible ce
smartphone pour l'instant autre point
hyper intéressant par rapport à la
concurrence et notamment l'iphone cette
es7 plus qu'on peut retrouver chez apple
c'est qu'il y a toujours une prise jack
c'est tout con mais quand on est
créateur de contenu la prise jack c'est
top pour quoi quant à un micro comme ça
et que tu veux le branché
quand tu fais un bloc en train de faire
leurs reportages ou n'importe quoi le
brancher sur ton téléphone tu prends la
prise jack sa du câble tu poses hop ça
te permet effectivement d'avoir
un outil pour pouvoir passer par tout
faire du blog est alors tableau
discrétion c'est pas ça mais en tout cas
tu peut le brancher sur le lay phone 7
et 7 plus ça tu oublies tu vas pas le
plugin directement dessus
c'est malheureusement pas possible
pourtant c'est vraiment devenu l'outil
indispensable notamment quand il fait du
blog utilise un petit trip hop comme
suit la lave est jolie tu mets ça hop
paf tu passes par tous et discret tu le
plug c'est indispensable donc c'est très
très bien que samsung ait gardé cette
prise jack
on sait très bien que ça me saoule
s'adresse énormément aux créateurs
contenu on le voit avec la caméra 360
avec la qualité de leurs appareils
photos bon qualité comporteront aussi
celle d'un iphone c'est pas le point de
comparaison
mais vraiment il s'adresse aux créateurs
de contenu on l'a vu lors de leur
dernière présentation la caméra 360 360°
je vais y arriver je te le disais les
lunettes verres c'est vraiment un pas
que prend samsung et le fait d'avoir
conservé le port mini jack c'est juste
top
autre point intéressant c'est la
certification ip67 qui lui permettent
effectivement d'être immergé pendant 30
minutes jusqu'à un mètre cinquante de
profondeur d'eau alors c'est pas de but
notre cas ça ça le rend étanche
je dirais que c'est un petit peu ce qui
se fait c'est ce qu'on attend
effectivement sur le prochain iphone 8
c'est ce qui se fait aujourd'hui sur
tous les téléphones bon il ya beaucoup
déjà son iphone 7 une certification ip67
la certification de 4,68 va un peu plus
loin terme d'étanchéité de résistance à
la poussière est effectivement à l'eau
c'est bien c'est un pas positif alors je
me suis pas rendu compte en essayant
mais ça fait partie des fiches
techniques et il faut pouvoir en parler
autre chose je me suis vraiment rendu
compte en essayant ce téléphone c'est la
rapidité la rapidité et la fluidité de
la bécane c'est à dire que quand tu
navigues droite gauche tu vas droit
pouces tu fermes
tu fais un test alors effectivement
synthes le produit est nouveau il vient
d'être sorti il n'est pas plein donc on
sait toujours que qu'une machine quand
elle est neuve elle carbure elle va très
très vite
mais là effectivement c'est assez
bluffant parce que ça va vite tu
navigues c'est rapide et c'est
extrêmement sympa l'appareil photo c'est
exactement le même jeu qui contrôle sur
le galaxy s est donc c'est un 8
mégapixels
je dis pas de bêtises par contre tu te
retrouves avec une caméra frontale une
caméra de face qui est beaucoup plus
sympa qui a eu 8 mégapixels qui est
améliorée fatalement parce qu'il fallait
pouvoir reconnaître le visage du cros
technisat celui qui le tient et aussi
son iris pour le déverrouillage
d'ailleurs j'ai regardé ses
impressionnants tu te rates tu
t'approches il ya ces deux tirs on tue
place des yeux en position pour salir
connaissent et se débrouille alors moi
j'étais sur un modèle de démos dont
forcément il y avait pas de
reconnaissance directement à cal calibré
pour mon oeil mais en attendant quand ça
a reconnu que ça bien calibrer la
position du haut de mes yeux ça a
déverrouillé directement le téléphone et
comme c'est une première en ce qui me
concerne c'est bluffant
point négatif de ce téléphone par contre
c'est bixby j'ai dit ça marche qu'en
anglais donc ça marche pas en france ils
nous l'ont survendu leur meneur qui note
moi j'étais super enthousiaste elle se
trouve que le concept de big bih et bien
c'est c'est du shérif plus c'est du
cirque et amélioré qui va reconnaître
les objets que tu as pu prendre en photo
ou que tu es en train de prendre en
photo et filmé qui va te le propose et
pour des solutions e-commerce ça ça a
plein de plein plein plein d'intérêt
sauf que là pour l'instant bigbee et ça
c'est vraiment la coupe du lancement ça
ne marche pas en français donc d'un big
ben dit tu as un bouton dédié qui est en
réalité un assistant vocal qui mue et
ses étangs bernardo à cette dernière 2 0
qui ne marche pas et ça franchement pour
un lancement c'est à louper et c'est
extrêmement dommage
autre point super intéressant alors je
te lis pareil ça je n'ai pas remarqué
parce que forcément j'ai pas pu m'en
rends compte en l'essayant pendant cinq
minutes mais c'est l'autonomie qui
annonçait et nous annonce une autonomie
de alors ça dépend de la consommation de
chacun un jour et demi à deux jours
si tu l'utilisent comme un foutu tout le
temps dessus connaît-elle fatalement pas
battre il va descendre beaucoup plus
vite et pour l'instant ce smartphone
non une autonomie qui est vraiment
remarquable par rapport à ce qu'on
trouve sur le marché ou trois
expositions parmi les tables du marché
entre point négatif c'est effectivement
le lecteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est placé au dos je vais essayer alors
je pense que c'est un coup à prendre va
pas cracher dans la soupe
il faut prendre le goût de positionner
son doigt vers l'appareil photo pour le
déverrouiller sur le fait que le faire
comme ça
en attendant je trouve que c'est pas
hyper pratique quand il prend le thé
rifains construit pas en compte le cesi
tu aurais plus naturellement tendance à
aller au milieu du smartphone car il
cherchait vers le haut c'est une
position qui ne paraît pas très naturel
et qui peut être sensiblement
inconfortable avec des grandes
guillemets avoir effectivement par
rapport aux rumeurs que tu as pu voir
d'ailleurs avoir ma vidéo c'est tu veux
voir sur le prochain iphone 8 vous
devrez retrouver un capteur au dos de
l'appareil mais partant que s'est
positionné au milieu ça paraît plus
logique donc peut-être que c'est quelque
chose qui sera corrigée pour le prochain
samsung galaxy s 9
on sait très bien que apple samsung
excusez moi est actuellement en train de
commencer à regarder à travailler pour
élaborer ce nouveau produit donc si
c'est des retours que samsung a souvent
ça te remettra ça leur permettra
peut-être d'en améliorer ce petit
capteur qui est de le descendre
légèrement milieu glisse est allé à voir
que c'est beaucoup plus sympa en terme
de manipulation
autre point qui est un petit peu négatif
tu t'en rends compte c'est que j'ai pu
tester y avait des petits jeux dessus
quand tu essayes un jeu tu te rends
compte que le jeu il est pas il exploite
pas à 100% les capacités l'écran alors
c'est pas la faute de samsung sont les
éditeurs tiers qui pour l'instant n'ont
pas adapté leur jeu à l'appareil
donc ce qui fait que tu as déjà des
petits bords et c'est emmerdant parce
que tu achètes un téléphone vous
utilisez année dans
écran ils vont pouvoir en profiter alors
que quand tu prends des jeux tout de
suite bas ça marche pas tu les as pas
dessus et ça c'est un peu dommage alors
ça ça va être corrigé
il faut pas s'inquiéter dès que les
éditeurs se seront un peu lancé dessus
ils vont faire des virées décor est
effectivement qui vont être adaptés à
cette version de 2,7 de cet appareil et
ça va être super sympa voilà ce que je
peux dire aujourd'hui sur 7 sur ce suite
que j'ai pu manipuler pendant je te lis
quelques minutes un appareil remarquable
l'écran comme on peut le voir dans les
vidéos c'est top c'est super sympa très
très agréable en termes de prise demain
maintenant pour l'instant moi je me
positionne pas sur le fait de me dire je
vais prendre celui là où je te répondre
à autre chose mais j'attends de voir ce
que va proposer réellement apple pour
pouvoir effectivement fait un bon choix
mais je pense en tout cas que 2017 ce
sera l'année du changement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
oh
est ce que ces brouillages
oui
l'alliage temps merci à toi bien marché
j'ai bien mangé quoi ça veut dire
ahmadi
un blog
[Musique]